i was not a  as rebellious as cassie was but you know  it's kind of fun i'm getting to live out  those like teenage experiences i never  really experienced before  like you're a good girl i i would never  do what she did on a carousel  like what  in fact you are such a good girl like  when you watched euphoria with your dad  well no see the problem was i completely  forgot to tell my dad i was doing  euphoria and um he sat down with my  grandparents and turned on euphoria and  how long did that last five minutes  yeah  and what did you say to him i got the  phone call what is this  what do you mean what is this because  euphoria go oh my god i completely  forgot to tell him  that's not the show you sit down with  nana